yeah yep the barking dog' experiment is
one of our favorites we do it very
frequently what a match it is a reaction
of n2o carbon disulphide and when you
ignite them you get a blue flame and a
great bush and when we recorded it in
slow motion we realized we didn't
understand the reaction as well as we
thought we did so now we've decided to
explore it a bit further and the first
thing we decided to do was instead of
having the tube vertically to have it
horizontally where I have never seen the
experiment done anyway except vertically
so this may be a real first
the first thing that's interesting is
that the gaslights long before the flame
actually gets to the edge of the tube
the second thing was that we noticed
something that we'd seen before the
flame shoots along the tube and then
suddenly stops and bounces and goes
rather more slowly but oscillating now
up till now we had assumed and it may be
the right explanation that the
experiment produces a shock wave that
hits the bottom of the test tube or the
big tube and comes back again so the
flame going this way meets the shock
wave coming back which stops it for a
minute like being thumped so we did
another experiment with a tube with a
rubber bung at the end instead of being
a closed big test tube what we thought
might happen the bang might shoot away
like a cannon
as before the flame started bouncing but
if there was a shockwave it wasn't
enough to remove the bun and if you
think about it it's really quite a heavy
bun anneal being a tough guy had pushed
it in my heart so then we thought let's
do the experiment with the tube open at
the bottom as far as I know nobody has
ever tried such an experiment at least
they may have tried it but I've never
seen it now we were really interested
what sort of noise it would make and it
made a different noise but the
technician who pulled out the bung was
so startled
he kicked over some glassware that was
nearby so all you can hear is a sort of
mixture of woosh and breaking glass
but the really interesting thing was
though if you watch it in high speed the
flame doesn't bounce anymore so the
explanation of the shockwave seems
really quite sensible but what is also
interesting is that the flame
accelerates as it goes down the tube so
what I think is happening is that the
flame front as it goes compresses the
gas just in front of it and raises the
temperature so the gas is getting hotter
and hotter so the reaction goes faster
and faster and then you get quite a
spectacular fireball coming out at the
end which is actually giving out blue
light and the blue light is the emission
of the excited electrons partly from
sulfur and partly from sulfur dioxide so
it's a really quite an exciting
experiment but it hasn't answered all
our questions so it's really quite
exciting it shows if you do more
experiments you learn more things but of
course it's given us lots more ideas so
in a video or twos time there'll be some
more excitement from The Barking Dog
subscribe to our Channel and you'll see
some more barking dogs in interesting
positions but actually what this video
footage is shown us is that it actually
goes in stages it's sort of good sort of
chugs its way to the bottom of the tube